he is one of the most popular and
enduring icons of the American West the
gentleman bandit who charmed his way
through life always keeping one step
ahead of the law with his fabled Wild
Bunch she terrorized the banks and the
railway companies during the closing
decade of the 19th century then he
headed south of the border only to meet
his match at the hands of Bolivian
troops in this week's by graphics we
delve into the life and the death of
Butch Cassidy Robert Leroy Parker was
born in Beaver Utah on April 3rd 1866 it
was named after his grandfather who
helped lead a group of Mormon handcart
refugees thousands of miles across the
country to the Autopia
that was Utah traveling along the Mormon
trail they pulled all of their
belongings in and carts with their faith
in Brigham Young and the Lord they
headed into the snowdrifts of the
Continental Divide Robert Parker senior
was a strong man
that's the harsh winter it was too much
for him that he was found dead one
morning frozen in his blanket the party
forged on and after many trials they
made it to Utah Parker's widow and
twelve-year-old son Max settled at
American Fork some 30 miles south of
Salt Lake City in 1865 they moved to
Beaver where max married Anne Campbell
the Cobb ball would go on so held
thirteen children together
Robert known as Bob he was the oldest
max Parker became a successful
businessman when Bob was a young child
his father purchased two ranch 12 miles
south of Circleville and moved the
family that he employed a number of
cowboys including a petty criminal by
the name of Mike Cassidy Cassidy took a
shine to young Bob who appeared to
idolize the swaggering outlaw he told
the boy how to shoot a gun
ride a horse rope and brand and rustle
cattle bob was a good study and by the
time he was 16 he had developed a
reputation as a fine short and a
competent horseman he developed into a
solid strapping teenager with a pleasant
and jovial personality there is no
known about butchers later teen years it
appears that he took work as a rancher
in various locations until 1884 at one
point he gains work as a butcher in Rock
Springs Wyoming it was at this time that
he took the nickname Bush the surname
Cassidy was a Amash to his childhood
hero Mike Cassidy Cassidy's first run-in
with the law occurred around 1880 he
wanted to buy some food and some clothes
but found the shop to be closed under
turns he simply broke in and took a pair
of jeans as well as a pie however he
also left an IOU note indicating that he
would return to settle his account later
the shopkeeper though he was not
impressed and he had butch arrested the
case ended up before the courts were a
jury acquitted him in 1889 a 23 year old
Butch Cassidy turned up in Telluride
Colorado located in the San Juan
Mountains Telluride was a wild mining
town full of gold hungry prospectors the
place was filled with saloons gambling
houses and brothels sitting right smack
in the middle of town was the San Miguel
Valley Bank Cassidy teamed up with a
fellow drifter by the name of Matt
Warner and the two were joint investors
in a racehorse named Betty the money for
that investment came through cattle
rustling they then decided to set their
sights a little higher determining to
raba the local bank it is believed that
they robbed a stage in Denver prior to
the bank heist they then made a show of
spending money liberally around
Telluride in order to show that they
were not desperate men on the morning of
June the 24th 1889 Cassidy Warner and
two accomplices one who is believed to
have been hairy longer bar better known
as the Sundance Kid hitched their horses
outside of the livery store in Telluride
and then headed for a saloon not far
from the San Miguel Valley Bank just
prior to noon they noticed one of the
tellers exit the bank leaving just one
man on duty two of the outlaws kept
guard outside while the other two went
to the bank amazingly none of the
robbers bothered to wear a mask or
otherwise conceal his identity history
also does not reveal the role that each
individual played we do know though that
one of the men who went into the bank
approached the loan teller and told him
that he wanted to cash a check when the
man began to inspect the check his head
was grabbed and shoved into the desk at
this point the two outside came in and
all four began ransacking the bank in
search of money they got away with more
than $20,000 on the way out of town
Cassidy and Warner were recognized by
two men still they managed to get away
hiding out in a remote area of
southeastern Utah known as robbers roost
this would become a favorite place of
escape the Cassidy and his gang who
built cabins there and kept their stolen
cattle horses and weaponry in this area
Cassidy used some of the profits from
that bank job to buy a ranch near Dubois
Wyoming in 1894 he began a relationship
with a teenage girl by the name of Ann
Bassett who was the daughter of a
wealthy cattle rancher for four years
after the San Miguel
Vanny bank robbery butch managed to live
the life of a law-abiding citizen
however shortly after becoming involved
with an he was arrested for horse
stealing his trial took place in Lander
Wyoming and resulted in his conviction
and sentence to two years imprisonment
at the Wyoming State Penitentiary in
Laramie Cassidy proved to be a model
prisoner he applied to the Wyoming
governor for an early release this was
agreed on the condition that he would
stay out of trouble in the future but he
agreed but he had no intention of
following through on that promise
immediately upon his release on January
the 19th 1896 he rejoined his gang at an
area of they're robbers roost hideaway
known as the hole in the wall
it was following Butch's release from
the Wyoming State Penitentiary that he
and his Wild Bunch gang began their
crime spree in earnest the gang was
enlarged more than 30 members with a
core of such notables as the Sundance
Kid kid curry and Elsa lay on the mid
afternoon of August the 13th 1896 three
men rode into Montpelier Idaho they
dismounted in front of the bank and then
two of them pulled their bandanas over
their faces
the bandits quickly pulled out their
revolvers and the two wearing bandanas
herded the men into the bank inside were
a number of customers and Bank employees
everyone except for one of the cashiers
was ordered to line up against the wall
one of the robbers who is believed to
have been Cassidy kept his gun trained
on the terrified customers while another
filled bags with cash gold and silver
before leaving with their $7,000 booty
Cassidy ordered the people to wait for
10 minutes before raising the alarm the
robber who had remained outside Bob
Meeks was the only one who did not cover
his face he was recognized by our town
residents and ended up being one of only
three people who was captured and
convicted of the crime Cassidy was well
known in uTorrent as a result had a
general rule of not committing crimes in
that state however in April of 1897 we
made an exception to that rule his
target was the payroll of the Pleasant
Valley coal company and cast gate this
was the largest coal mine in Carbon
County Utah furthermore it was ideally
located between the gangs favorite
hideouts of robbers roost and Browns
hole the company knew that their payroll
was an enticing prize for bandits and so
they tried to prevent heists by keeping
irregular paydays the payroll came in on
a train that was heavily guarded butch
decided that going up against the train
was too risky and so he determined to
take the money directly from the
paymaster in order to do so however the
gang would need to know when the payroll
was going to arrive on April the 17th
Cassidy rode into the town of Castle
gate and went to one of the saloons
where he inquired if there was any work
going for a ranch and he was told that
there might be if he was patient enough
with his excuse for hanging around now
established he made his way to the train
depot
he watched the goings-on as the train
came and went and then returned to the
saloon for the next week he repeated
this process observing every train that
came into town on April the 22nd
these patients it was finally rewarded a
whistle from the mine announced that it
was payday when the train arrived Butch
watched from a distance as the paymaster
fi carpenter runs a couple of aides
carried moneybags from the train to his
office the bags were ever you containing
more than seven thousand dollars in gold
and over 100 dollars in silver so the
men were going slowly then just as they
ready to climb the stairs for the
paymaster's office carpenter was
approached from behind and a revolver
was poked into his ribs butch informs
him that he was about to relieve him and
his pals of their load adding that it
hate to have to shoot any of them
carpenter was stunned that such a brazen
attack would be attempted in broad
daylight
there were plenty of miners arounds but
very few of them spoke English or would
have been aware of what was going on
gang member al Saleh emerged from the
shadows and helped butch take possession
of the money bags carpenter and his
helpers left them to its seeking
protection in the nearby hardware store
the paymaster then began yelling out
that had been robbed Cassidy and Lai
attempted to mount their horses while
stowing the money in their saddlebags if
a butcher's horse got spooked and took
off leaving him standing in the middle
of the street with a bag of gold in his
hand
lai managed to track the horse down and
bring it back to the - and they made
away with over $7,000 in gold they left
the bag of silver just lying in the
street pay master carpenter now sprang
into action he ran from the telegraph
office and instructed the clerk to send
an urgent message to the authorities in
price which was some 10 miles away
however the clerk told him that the
lines had been cut thinking fast he made
for the Train and told the driver to
hightail it to price as the train
chugged along it went right past the
fleeing Roberts it took several hours
before the sheriff at price could get a
posse organized in addition to having
this headstart butch was also very
familiar with the countryside and was
easily able to evade his pursuers local
ranchers were also happy to provide his
gang with fresh horses having no loyalty
to the big mining companies or indeed
the banks Cassidy and Leigh they made it
back to their base at robbers roost
where they lay low with the other gang
members the officials in Utah were well
aware of where the robbers were but
showed no enthusiasm for going after
them as a result the local papers began
to accuse the lawman of cowardice for
three months Butch and his men spend
their time drinking gambling and horse
riding
then when the boredom was too much they
decided to go out and start spending
their takings they ranged around buying
fine clothes getting haircuts and
spending up large in the saloons and the
brothels by the end of June 1897 it was
time to get back to the business of
robbery the gang set their sights on the
town of Belle Fouche north of Black
Hills On June the 28th which sent
gangnam botamo day to scout out the town
the plan was to rob the bank once a day
had got him back however a day managed
to get himself drunk and didn't return
to camp until it was far too late an
angry butch had to delay the heist for
24 hours the next day butch selected the
Sundance Kid along with George Currie
Walt put me and Tom O'Day to do the job
that's the Butte County Bank the three
men followed the usual procedure drawing
their revolvers and forcing the
customers to stand along the wall with
their hands in the air
however passerby saw this through the
window and they raised the alarm chaos
erupted on the street as people rushed
to get off the street while others went
for their guns
the bandits inside they quickly realized
that they'd been found out they rushed
out firing their guns in the air and
attempting to get away a couple of
townspeople returned fire from behind
cover kid Carrie was unable to get to
his horse so tried to mount a mule only
to discover that it wouldn't move as the
other two rode out of town Tom O'Day
attempted to steal away into a side
street but was caught and held overnight
in the local bank vaults before being
transported to the jail and Deadwood the
very next day the robbery had been an
unmitigated disaster it had cost the
gang a valued member and earned them
just $97 leaving behind $3,000
[Music]
in the early morning hours of June the
2nd 1899 the Wild Bunch pulled off one
of their most celebrated crimes two
members of the gang with Redlands uns
Flags down the Union Pacific Overland's
Flyer train just outside of the Wilcox
station in Wilcox Wyoming the driver
thought the two men were warning him
that the driving rain had washed out an
approaching bridge he throw on the
brakes bring the train to a screeching
halt but when he saw that the men had
guns drawn he realized the truth and
began running down the track to Warner
coming trains back off the bandits let
him go and jumped onto the train where
they ordered the engineer to pull the
train into a nearby trestle on the far
side of the bridge once the train had
crossed over one of the bandits lit the
fuse to a stash of dynamite which had
been placed on the bridge the bridge was
damaged enough that the second train
would be unable to follow the train
engineer then ordered the train forward
another two miles where the rest of the
gang were waiting the robbers then made
their way to the Express car only to
find out that the guard he wasn't gonna
open the door so they decided to blow it
open with dynamite this rattled the
guard to the extent that he couldn't
remember the combination to the safe
so well the robbers blew that open as
well the result was that all the cash
went flying everywhere
still the gang managed to get away with
more than fifty thousand dollars worth
of cash goals and jewelry the robbery
made national headlines and brought the
Wild Bunch to the attention of the
nation's premier crime fighter's the
Pinkerton Detective Agency for the next
two years the Pinkertons doggedly
tracked down the gang meanwhile the
posse was formed to chase down the train
robbers they caught up with the three
bandits on June the 6th at Castle Creek
a gun battle ensued in which kid Carrie
shot and killed the sheriff leading the
posse the other posse members then
withdrew as the outlaws escaped
Butch Cassidy was not of the
rough-and-tumble moles most of his
contemporary outlaws where he was an
extremely sociable man who was a great
conversationalist we're not engaged in
criminal activity he impressed others
with his strong work ethic by 1899 he
had a thriving ranch in Dubois Wyoming
and was growing tired of the outlaw life
in the summer of that year he visited
the office of attorney Orlando powers in
Ogden Utah he explained to the attorney
that he had been portrayed as a vicious
criminal when in fact he has never hurt
anybody and had only ever robbed from
large corporations Bush then urged
powers to approach the governor on his
behalf seeking an amnesty deal the
lawyer responded that a deal was
extremely unlikely and the best thing
that butch could do was to go back into
hiding undeterred butch sought out
another attorney this time a meeting was
arranged with Utah governor Herbert
Wells wells was impressed by Cassidy and
told him that as long as there were no
outstanding murder warrants for him he
was sure that amnesty could be arranged
the second meeting was arranged which
butch attended in full confidence he was
surprised to learn however that the
governor's office had uncovered an
outstanding murder warrant in his name
butch protested that it never killed a
man in his life he didn't have had to
though the governor responded the mere
charge was enough it meant that amnesty
was simply out of the question
[Music]
with the failure of his attempt to go
straight it seems that butch carried out
a string of further robberies around the
turn of the century here in the Sundance
Kid have been linked to a train robbery
in Tipton Wyoming in august of nineteen
hundred and the Winnemucca Nevada bank
heist a month later though there is no
concrete evidence that they took part
with no prospects to end his fugitive
life in the West which began making
plans to head south of the border when
he proposed the idea to his gang members
only two were interested the Sundance
Kid and kicked curry before the gang
split up for good it's five core members
had a final rendezvous in Texas after
having their fill of liquor fine dining
and women they sat for a group
photograph in new suits the photo that
was taken on that day made its way to
the Pinkerton Detective Agency and it
was used on wanted posters Butch and
Sundance then split up promising to meet
up again in New York City this they did
with Sundance being accompanied by his
longtime girlfriend at a place
the trio boarded the ship hermanos bound
for Buenos Aires on February the 20th
[Music]
immediately upon arrival butch using the
assumed name of Jim Ron deposited
$12,000 in a local bank as the first
step in putting up a land claim they
ended up purchasing 17,000 acres of
lands in shalil owe to their neighbors
they appeared to be hardworking gringos
except for one disturbing fact wherever
they went they wore their guns Butch and
Sundance had presumed that a move out of
the country would bring an end to their
pursuit by the Pinkertons but they were
mistaken
Robert Pinkerton the head of the agency
sent a letter to the Buenos Aires Police
Chief with descriptions and photos of
the duo
the local police identified them as the
two ranchers who always wore guns around
Ciolino they attempted to keep a close
surveillance on the men until the
Pinkertons arrived and apprehended them
the two outlaws would spend seven years
in Argentina before the law finally
caught up with them for the first five
years they kept their noses clean
blending in with the locals and becoming
popular members of the Cholula community
then for some reason they returned to a
life of crime in the spring of 1906 they
teamed up with another American fugitive
and robbed the bank in Mercedes getting
away with $20,000 however one of the
three robbers shot and killed a bank
teller
once again Butch and Sundance were on
the run
ah November the sick the animals made
their way to San Vincente Bolivia they
were put up in the spare room of a local
villager however a local official
identified them and notified members of
the Bolivian cavalry the room where
Butch and Sundance were holed up was
surrounded there are a number of
versions as to how the last moments
played out the most accepted version is
that Sundance sprinted out onto the
patio in a desperate attempt to get some
rifles these were located by an outside
wall and he was firing his revolvers
into the air as a distraction as he ran
however he was cut down before he made
it off the patio butch ran out after him
and dragged his mortally wounded friend
back inside sustaining at least one
wound in the process after pouring
masses have led into the building and
hearing only silence from within the
Bolivian troops finally made their way
inside they found the bodies of the two
outlaws lying on the floor
Sundance had been shot several times in
the arms and once in the forehead while
butch had a bullet hole in the temple
the soldiers inferred that butch had put
his best friend out of his misery before
turning the gun on himself
however there was never an inquest and
the two men were never formally
identified the most wanted men in
America were simply buried in unmarked
graves so I really hope you found their
video interesting if you did please do
give us a thumbs up below and don't
forget to subscribe brand new videos
just like this every day of the week if
you look at something else to watch
right now do you check out our other
videos linked to on the screen and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]
you